back to work for Matthew McConaughey -
not on a movie set but soon a college
classroom what are you studying here
government alright that's what I was
gonna do for a while
and they've done a film school yeah what
class is Matthew teaching so we all know
where to sign up it's the script to
screen class at his alma mater the
University of Texas Austin hook em horns
thank you very much
Matthew graduated back in 1993 and has
been a visiting instructor since 2015 oh
and the syllabus Matthews own movies of
course he'll even take students to set
some times so I said you know what let's
get a class take them on a chronological
journey the pal script gets to the
screen the 49 year old says it's the
class I wish I would have had when I was
in film school Matthew isn't the only
star turn teacher Oakbridge lectured at
Northwestern Angelina Jolie taught at
the London School of Economics Amal
Clooney taught law at Columbia even
Kanye's taught a class in fashion design
what are you studying there y'all know
that that's what y'all want to do too
when you get out then when I was here I
did not know what it was that I wanted
to do et was with Matthew on the Texas
campus back in 2008 right after some
Levi's was born where my son goes to
school will end up being a being his
choice and but it'll be something what
he said we decide together I'll be able
to share nothing but great experiences
that I had here and he'll probably be a
fan because we'll be at quite a few
games and he's already getting that
little sign working on his fingers
[Music]